31 15 bonsoir monsieur je vous écoute
est ce que vous considérez comme bêtise
et pourquoi vous dites que vous êtes
nuls
vous avez déjà eu des idées suicidaires
pour faire avancer la première fois
la première fois d'accord
vous avez déjà pensé un scénario c'est
juste quelque chose qui vous est souvent
saturé
d'accord
sauter d où
il faut vraiment leur demander avez vous
des idées suicidaires clairement et
certaines personnes finalement sont
soulagés parce qu'on leur demande et du
coup un fruit donc là je peux dire oui
parce qu'ils sont prêts à accueillir une
réponse santé dans l'entourage familial
c'est vrai quand il ya les affecte aussi
qu'ils se mêlent c'est difficile
d'accueillir l'entendre que son conjoint
de son enfant de son père ou de sa mère
que bah ça va pas et qu'on pense à
mourir parce que justement ça va pas
[Musique]
prenez votre temps à région
non ça fait longtemps vous avez des
idées suicidaires renier votre temps
vous n'avez pas le faire
voyez donc pour vos enfants à votre mari
vous n'allez pas le faire
ils vont dire ah bah oui mais hier oui
non il s'est passé un petit quelque
chose mais bon et ils vont pas
d'expliquer ils attendent que nous on
leur tend la perche donc du coup on va
leur dire bah qu'est ce qui s'est passé
justement hier qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui
ça ne va pas bien ce point et du coup le
fait qu'ils soient écoutés qu'on ait
entendu ce petit mot qui finalement
n'est pas grand chose mais on a réussi à
tirer un peu le fil de la pelote pour
justement mettre le doigt sur ce qui va
pas justement ce jour là parfois ils
vont nous dire je veux va la jouer en
finir tu veux tout arrêter où je ne
pourrais ressentir du coup c'est
important de me poser la question est ce
qu'ils veulent mourir et parfois c'est y
voient la volonté d'arrêter de souffrir
pas forcément de mourir est en tout cas
si c'est de mourir mais poser les
questions à quoi ils ont pensé un ce
qu'ils ont pensé à un scénario est ce
qu'ils ont les moyens de le faire ça
c'est des questions qu'on pose
naturellement et les gens répondent
facilement et naturellement aussi soit
ils disent non j'ai pas pensé soit oui
oui je sais que le train il passe à
telle heure à telle gars
vous avez déjà fait des tentatives
durable
là encore vous avez fait
vous en avez fait que confirmer vidéo
les autres il y en a plusieurs que vous
aviez fait comment les autres fois
[Musique]
ouais parce que là il faut faire quelque
chose on est d'accord
[Musique]
non vous pouvez pas continuer comme ça
là je suis d'accord avec
les personnes qui sont seules c'est
quand ils rentrent chez eux après la
journée travaillée qui sont plus lien
avec le ballon les collègues de boulot
la société en général tout ça qui se
retrouve vraiment seuls chez eux et baky
du coup les angoisses arrivent les idées
suicidaires parce que voilà on se rend
compte qu'on est seul donc voilà il
s'est de plus en plus pesant et du coup
un peu plus compliqué vous avez envie de
mourir des piscines
donc c'est plus pour arrêter une
souffrance
l'accord
vous ressentez de la tristesse si on a
une situation qui est un peu compliqué
si par exemple on doit faire envoyer des
secours mais ta personne n'est pas
d'accord mais que non juge que c'est
nécessaire là maintenant tout de suite
me demanda un collègue de faire si on
n'a pas l'adresse de fer géolocalisés
par le samu lapland la personne qui nous
appelle t-on encore on la tient au
téléphone jusqu'à ce que les secours
arrivent vous avez déjà fait des
tentatives de castrés l'équipe des nues
qui arrivent
ils vont pas tarder d'ici une demi-heure
ils vont arrêter son style
est l un de nous qui restait jusque 23h
en france on a entre dix et douze mille
décès par suicides par an dès entre 200
et 220 ou voire 250 milles tentatives de
suicides par an en france le tabou reste
encore du reste encore cachées sont
encore pour beaucoup assorti d'un
sentiment de honte très important mais
la preuve en est l'entretien que nous
avons on parle maintenant beaucoup plus
facilement de pensées suicidaires
d'idées de suicides au risque suicidaire
que on en parlait il ya cinq ans il ya
dix ans
mais jamais par téléphone c'est plus
facile aussi puis on se connaît pas donc
c'est plus facile aussi
du coup ça a baissé un petit peu
d'attention de fait qu'on dispute un
petit peu
ouais là vous avez toujours ses idées
[Musique]
ça c'est bien j'ai eu un bon effet sur
moi l'heure du conte